a big shift is on the way in the U.S
government's efforts to try to control
illegal immigration President Biden is
sending 1500 soldiers and Marines to the
U.S Mexico border where they will help
deal with an expected jump in the number
of Asylum Seekers from Central and South
America this group here is about 3 000
strong there headed to Mexico City and
plan to move to the Border after a
change in U.S policy kicks in next week
Nancy Cordes is at the White House for
us Nancy good morning
Tony good morning to you the first of
these 1500 troops
troops reprehend migrants they'll play a
supporting role to border patrol agents
who are bracing for what could be a
record-breaking number of migrants all
seeking Asylum at once
U.S troops are being rushed to the
border to help deal with this
an increase in migrants that is expected
to swell next Thursday when the pandemic
era rule known as title 42 expires these
troops arrive as early as May 10th and
then in the coming weeks title 42 was
put in place as covid began to spread in
March of 2020. the rule made it easier
to expel migrants seeking Asylum now
that it's about to end you're already
seeing it South of the Border Caravans
trying to move up they know when title
42 expires it's already putting a strain
on cities like El Paso Texas where
hundreds of migrants are camping outside
homeless shelters because there's no
room inside I am declaring a state of
emergency in our community Customs and
Border Patrol officials say they're
preparing for as many as 10 000 migrants
to cross the southern border every day
that's nearly doubled the daily average
from March for the next 90 days 1500 U.S
troops will temporarily supplement the
2500 National Guard troops that are
already on the border they're not
authorized to serve as law enforcement
but they can provide logistical support
like transportation and narcotics
detection it frees up those Frontline
border patrol Personnel to go back out
on patrol John sandweg is a former Chief
of Immigration and Customs Enforcement I
really think this is what the
administration is trying their hardest
to avoid or scenes like we saw before we
had large camps setting up in El Paso of
Haitian migrants that's why I think
they're committed to avoiding
Democrats and Republicans actually agree
that one of the biggest problems is the
shortage of immigration judges and
clerks who can process the backlog of
Asylum claims but because Congress
hasn't addressed the problem Gail
migrants who do manage to apply for
Asylum will likely have to wait years
for a decision
oh boy thank you very much Nancy